so there are rumors about tristan
thompson
currently who is khloe kardashian's baby
daddy
while he was with her i guess he had
gotten a personal trainer pregnant and
she is currently
suing him because i guess they had
hooked up while he was in houston on his
birthday and she was trying to get child
support out of him he said i'm not going
to give you child support i'm actually
going to retire next year so your child
support is going to be based off of my
unemployment status so you're not going
to get a lot especially in texas so she
then proceeds to move to california
where
the child support laws would be very
different since we're very loyal because
he plays for the kings sacramento kings
right yes and so she moved here with the
thought that she could get more money
out of him he then tried to shush her by
saying sign this basically sign away
like you're right
to speaking about me take the 75 000
and be happy with it she then went to
like media outlets and started like
leaking the story everything which is
now why we're talking about it you you
think he's stressed out over this
i mean he cares
no he's done it time and time again he
cheated on his first baby mama with yeah
i mean that's a child he's going to have
that's a big paycheck i mean you know
was he is he like a superstar does he
have a lot no no the only reason why
he's ever really in the news is because
he keeps cheating on chloe
that's really that's what it is yeah and
there were text messages that got leaked
where he was basically saying you need
to take the 75
uh 75 000 settlement because what you're
going to be left with is a fatherless
child that's why you sat in texas oh see
my problem okay
not a good guy if you're not a good kid
bro you gotta that that's your deal take
care of that [ __ ] kid and it's fully
confirmed that he's the baby daddy yes
he's not even denying do the rights oh
yeah yeah do the right thing yeah man
you're just gonna have a kid and then
just not father that's gonna
it's not the kid's [ __ ] fault i don't
respect that guy at all
i mean you know i think that's such
[ __ ] mm-hmm yeah
jordan craig
yeah that is the uh
first uh mother of his children because
he had a son with his girl then
girlfriend jordan craig he then cheated
on her with khloe kardashian had a child
with chloe stayed with chloe did not
father his first son for
for a hot minute while he was dating
chloe and now he's doing the same thing
he's i hate people he's just a young
rich he's an [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah he you
you don't you have children don't father
them [ __ ] you i have zero respect for
that guy grill him to the wall man make
him pay look at his son look at him it's
beautiful
beautiful little boy and probably
ignores him then [ __ ] you and that's and
that's the you that's the
uh
that's true if that's what he's doing i
don't know what he's doing i don't know
the answers if that's what he's if if
he's not being a father to that kid then
shame on him and and i think there's no
excuse if that's the case
don't give a [ __ ] what your past was i
don't care if you're young you know
better and if you have a child you're
responsible for that child [ __ ] you
otherwise [ __ ] you
that's what i have to say
well said bro i have zero
there are no excuses i don't give a [ __ ]
about anything
take care of your kid thank you what was
your question chabelle i know i know
i know you're feeling that stuff
can i get your take on this